هتنورنا من بيروت الكاتبه ومؤلفه مسلسل
للموت نادين جابر يسعد مساكي نادين اهلا
بك شكرا على تواجدك معانا في مسائل عربيه
وبرمضان
شكرا لالك حبيبتي مساء الخير لالك اهلا بك
يعني الموت بجزئه ثالث يدخل السباق
الرمضاني هذا العام بعد النجاح الكبير
الجزء الاول والثاني من للموت ومطالبات
كثيره من الجمهور باستكمال بجزء الثالث
اولا انت ككاتبه
الموت 3 او الموت واحد واثنين وثلاثه كيف
هو شعورك بهذا النجاح اللي حققه وشو سر
هذا النجاح وهل التكامل بين الاجزاء
اكيد النجاح حلو خاصه لما يكونوا بعد تعب
وتحدي والصرار المسؤوليه كانت كتير كبيره
خاصه بهيدا الجزء الحمد لله بتكون كتير
روعه ومبسوطين كلنا كفريق عمل السر هم
نجاح هو الخلطه بين فريق العمل ككل انا ما
بقدر انصب نجاح مسلسل لشخص واحد بل هو
فريق عمل كامل متكامل بدي انا من النص
للاخراج للممثلين للانتاج هول العناصر
الاربعه ضروريه يكونوا بحياه الله مسلسل
لحتى يكون ناجح واذا حيا لعنصر كان اقل
بتصير فيه غلط بالنتيجه اها بس نادين نحن
بنحكي عن ثلاث اجزاء اليوم فكيف يعني
تمكنتي من انه تبقي على التشويق ثلاث
مواسم ولا تقعي في فخ المماطله
عن جد كانت المسؤوليه كتير كبيره خاصه
بالجزء الثالث كرمال هيك انا لما لما طلب
مني بناء على تلفزيونات والمنصات
والجمهوريه اللي بدهن بالحاح جزيء ثالث
اخدت فتره اني فكر بالموضوع لانه
الجزء الثالث
فكانت الخبريه اني اخذ وقت لحتى اقدر
الاقي حبكه ورد لهم خبر بعد شي شهر اذا
انا عندي شي بقعد اقوله ولا لا انا شخص ضد
الاجزاء طالما عندي شي بعد قوله من بعد
شهر ونصف
من التفكير العميق توصلت لنتيجه انه بمحل
ناس حابين هالمسلسل وهالشخصيات بس نحن
ضروره ضروره انه نعمل شوي قلبي بالمسلسل
احسن ما نعيد حالنا انا بعيد حالي
تمثيل
والمخرج ذات الشيء فكان في ضروره انه
ضروره درام
تروحي على بلد ثاني وتفوتي بشخصيات جديده
[موسيقى]
للتغييرات الدراميه ونفوت بمسلسل منفصل
ومتصل بزيت الوقت لانه لو كنت انا فتت
بالجزء الثالث بزيت الحلقه اللي درت فيها
بالحلقه الثانيه كنت كنت قشطت وكانت يمكن
الناس حب وحلقه واثنين وثلاثه واربعه
وخمسه رجعوا حسوا بالملل وتركوا
المسلسل
جديد يعتبر يعني بس الشخصيات المسلسل يشوف
قديش كان في بطوله نسائيه رائعه وبامتياز
سر ارتكاز نادين في عمالها على البطوله
النسائيه وعلى العنصر او الشخصيه النسائيه
القويه لحمل
الدراما او الثقل الدرامي صح التعبير في
العمل الفني
مضبوط انا من الاشخاص يلي دايما بالدراما
انا شخص بنادي بالانفتاح بتحفيز المراه
بحقوق القانونيه والاجتماعيه فبحب دائما
انا امراه بالنهايه وبعرف يعني هموم
الامراه بشكل عام فبحب سله الضوء دايما
على اكثر شويه على على الامراه لانه اهمها
كتافه لانه انا وحده منهم طب نادين يعني
انت كتير أكترتي من جرعه الكوميديا لساريه
الممثله كارولا عبود هلا تريحينا شوي لانه
بتضل اعصابنا متوتره من اول الحلقه لاخرها
لعبت من الاشخاص ياللي بسمع النقد اذا كان
بمحله من اشخاص بيفهموا دراما ومن اشخاص
عم يحكوا بضمير وبعدم تجريع سمعت هديك
السنه بالجزء الثاني انه كان المسلسل كتير
دار للدرجه المشاهد عن جد
بقلبه من كثره الاحداث القليمه
ونحن كشعب بلبنان والشعب الشعب العربي ككل
خلقه من القهر ومن الوجع بده على باله شي
يرتاح فيه هلا انا مسلسل للموت ما فيني
اطلع
لجاره جديده
اني اخفف جرعه القهر بالجزء الثالث ويزيد
جرعه الكوميديا لحتى اعمل توازن اذا كان
في اذا كان في حدث كثير موجع ارجع ريح من
بعض المشاهد طيب شكرا جزيلا لك من بيروت
الكاتبه ومؤلفات مسلسل للموت نادره جابر
شكرا
[موسيقى]